[Musique]
alors qu'un nouveau prêtre en vie paris
qui est formidable et les comment il est
jeune
moi c'est surtout sa voix que j'ai
apprécié parce que vous manquiez
d'hommes qu'il arrive à tous vous
assumez comme ça c'est tout
c'est mon parle pour toi ces biens
détenus
sept ans et demi que je suis ici vous
croyez
oh
ya longtemps que vous ne vous êtes pas
confessé n'est ce pas tu crois pas en
dieu de vous monter quelques fois la
dernière fois c'était un soldat
un droit qui passe dans votre église ne
compte pas me suis relevé
j'aurais trouvé les mots convertir c'est
être faut qu'ils firent afin de faire
changer d'avis ça vous convient me tête
de mule
qu'est ce que vous foutez leur sac est
ce que tu penses tu perds morin et
sympathique en assurance mais j'espère
vous donne envie tout faire pour
déstabiliser
quand je vous écoute j'ai l'impression
qu'on parlait depuis notre planète
qu'est ce que ça peut vous faire au fond
qu'il gagne ou qu'il en ait pas comme
qu'est ce que ça peut me faire mais ça
change tout mais ce qu'on fait on dira
que c'est le dit a pris vous avez un
croche patte
alors qu'on passe beaucoup de temps soit
je n'avance choisissez pas réciproque
je lui parle et je vais à pression qui
s'en fout que des détails
[Musique]
les allemands ont un effet dix otages
voulait fusiller sur place le père
morand
[Musique]